tous les présidents de la république
avaient à leur disposition moi ce que je
regrette c'est que on joue les saintes
nitouches regardez par exemple les
fuites la levée du secret d'instruction
françois fillon est auditionné c'est une
heure après dans les journaux monsieur
leroux est auditionné vous avez vu que
c'était dans les journaux il a
démissionné 24 heures mais après il a
été auditionné par les juger par la
police
y'a rien qui n'est sorti c'est
extraordinaire il ya deux poids deux
mesures pourquoi comment est-ce que ça
sort parce que quand on est ambitieux né
il ya une note qui passe au procureur et
qui est donnée à au ministre de la
justice c'est l'article 39 1 du code de
procédure pénale c'est obligatoire et ça
va vers le prix un public qui en fait ce
qu'il veut qui peut la redonner le fait
que celle ci l'a fait le parc national
financier qui du coup ne va pas autant
est ce que vous demandiez vous voyez
quoi lorsque les choses quand me quand
on regarde le patrimoine de monsieur
macro diano n'y a rien à regarder alors
que beaucoup de gens se posent des
questions
quand on dit mais tu es folle a
peut-être prendre quand même enquêté
pourquoi parce que pécresse elle en a
subi les conséquences quand son fils a
été pris avec trois grammes de cannabis
s'était tout de suite dans les journaux
et pourquoi pas se veut dire simplement
qui a une volonté de françois fillon de
nuire à la droite
mais on le sait très bien mais est-ce
que de françois hollande de france au
lapsus françois hollande
en somme ils s'appellent tous françois
françois mitterrand qu'il a les moyens
d'aller jusqu'au bout délit dit je te
demanderai des comptes z et il a des
problèmes et moi